[Music]  this is candor where everyone has a  story  who is it against the whole wide world  meaning is me you know cause he never  let nobody rub up on you giving you a  chance ending experience on a  transcendent experience over to church  [Music]  we are going out  [Music]  Raymond very handsome weekend gorgeous  thank you it's where do you live what do  you do  you go kids you have a little questions  all right cause you touched  [Music]  sexy ankle bracelet  yes I'm nada I was an idiot and I was  unlucky  [Music]  hello is this um your mom's made amazing  pretty good see okay see you you are  just told me I'm keeper in cage  [Music]  [Applause]  I know that changes can't just go keys  [Music]  [Applause]  d1 corn you  [Music]  you  you